bonjour claude heureuse de vous
retrouver ce matin dans la matinale
berthet france alors après le départ des
américains est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
vide politique en afghanistan
oui en effet la situation et comparé par
certains analystes à celle du sud
vietnam lorsque les troupes américaines
ont décidé de se retirer en 1973 et qui
a abouti à la chute de saigon deux ans
plus tard les situations restent ils
sont pas comparables parce que
l'environnement est tout à fait
différent la géopolitique aussi est
différente mais il est vrai qu'il
pourrait y avoir certaines d'analogie
aujourd'hui les talibans revendiquent le
contrôle de 85% du territoire afghan
c'est peut-être un chiffre exagéré mais
il est vrai qu'ils contrôlent une partie
des campagnes mais ils ont été bien
accueillis bien accueilli parce que tout
simplement ils rétablissent l'ordre un
ordre talibans mais qui est comme tout
de même un ordre et que maintenant ils
s'en prennent aux principales villes
probablement qu'ils les éviteront de
s'attaquer à kaboul pendant un certain
temps pour éviter que les américains ne
perdent la face et les américains vont
certainement faire le nécessaire pour
que l'aéroport de kaboul qui est
vraiment l'élément stratégique parce que
ces salaires encore de kaboul qui vit ce
pays à l'extérieur
et bien soit défendu et c'est en
principe les turcs qui vont assurer la
défense de l'aéroport de kaboul
avec naturellement les forces
gouvernementales les talibans à engager
des conversations sous la pression
américaine y compris avec le
gouvernement de kaboul
mais
il ne montre aucune volonté aucun
appétit pour que ces négociations
aboutissent parce qu'ils qualifient tout
simplement le gouvernement de kaboul de
gouvernement fantoche qui a été installé
par les américains et par conséquent ils
veulent que ce gouvernement sans lag et
ils sont certainement pas prêts à faire
un gouvernement d'union nationale avec
le gouvernement de kaboul
ce qu'ils veulent c'est gagner
progressivement du terrain
les campagnes les petites villes puis
les villes moyennes puis les grandes
villes est finalement naturellement
l'objectif ultime sera kaboul
ça sera plus difficile parce que la
population a évolué et la société civile
qui existe dans les grandes villes
résistera aux talibans et surtout à la
loi talibane avec notamment des
organisations de la société civile les
femmes qui craignent l'imposition de la
charia
avec tout ce que cela implique pour
l'éducation des jeunes filles pour le
port du voile et pour le statut de la
femme en général il y a comité de
réconciliation nationale qui est
présidée par monsieur abdullah abdullah
qui était le rival de monsieur camille
l'actuel président à kaboul
mais monsieur abdullah abdullah voit
bien qu'il n'arrivera pas à constituer
une base de réconciliation nationale et
que et le gouvernement par conséquent
d'union nationale que les américains
appellent de leurs voeux ne verra
probablement pas le jour
c'est en quelque sorte un retour à la
case départ de 2001 quels sont les pays
qui s'intéressent aujourd'hui et ils
étaient nombreux en 2001 à l'avenir de
l'afghanistan
il y en a beaucoup il ya d'abord tous
les pays voisins bien sûr
je dirai au premier chef peut-être le
tadjikistan parce que le tadjikistan à
une frontière commune très poreuse avec
l'afghanistan
ça n'est pas nouveau mais le tadjikistan
qui a dû accueillir la semaine dernière
mille soldats du gouvernement afghan qui
se sont réfugiées précipitamment parce
qu'ils étaient poursuivis par les
talibans qui à l'ailé les tailler en
pièces c'était évidemment une situation
très difficile mais le tadjikistan est
un allié militaire de la russie fait
partie de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective il y a une base
militaire russe à douchanbé et
d'ailleurs les français connaissent bien
à cette situation puisque une
intervention française aux côtés des
américains en afghanistan jusqu'en 2014
se faisait avec une base de gisti
carrière à douchanbé c'est probablement
le pays qui risque d'être le plus
affecté par une déstabilisation
vraisemblable de l'afghanistan y en a
d'autres le betis tant pour des raisons
semblables
ce métis temps est un pays moins
fragiles et plus riches que le
tadjikistan le turkménistan
mais qui lui aussi est dans une
situation un peu différente et il a de
grosses ressources pétrolières la chine
est là c'est un acteur très important
parce que la chine qui propose déjà de
participer à la reconstruction peut-être
de certaines infrastructures en
afghanistan et les talibans lien vite
les talibans ont dit qu'il garantissait
la sécurité des investissements chinois
la sécurité des travailleurs chinois qui
pourrait être liée à cet investissement
nous simplement les rêves et chinois
après le craignent beaucoup la
déstabilisation et son effet de
contamination éventuelle sur les
ouigours qui sont les voisins immédiats
de l'afghanistan et qui sont également
des musulmans actuellement maltraité par
le régime de pékin
et puis il ya les rangs qui est un
acteur très important dans la région
mais qui a une frontière
assez longue avec l'afghanistan qui
s'intéressent aussi donc beaucoup à la
situation et enfin le pakistan a fait
donc six pays voisin le pakistan
on se souvient que les groupes
terroristes se réfugie fréquemment au
pakistan que ce soit des groupes
terroristes comme al qaïda
c'est d'ailleurs au pakistan qu'il y a
dix ans les troupes spéciales
américaines ont pu tuer ben laden
puisqu'ils s'étaient finalement réfugié
au pakistan à abbottabad là où se trouve
le saint-cyr pakistanais avec
probablement pendant assez longtemps une
protection delà de la delà de la
sécurité militaire pakistanaise
et puis ils ne sont pas voisins
géographiquement mais ils sont des
paysages ap de la région l'inde qui est
très inquiète d'une éventuelle
déstabilisation au pakistan avec l'aide
de groupes terroristes pakistanais ou
ayant lors leur base au pakistan qui ont
fait les attentats en inde en plus
évidemment
la russie qui a une expérience
extrêmement douloureuse en afghanistan
entre 1979 et 1989
à l'époque de l'union soviétique et qui
au moment de l'attentât des twin towers
le 11 septembre 2001 eh bien monsieur
poutine avait dit à monsieur bush qu'il
l'aiderait pour lutter contre al qaïda
dans l'intervention initiale citée le
but de l'intervention initiale des états
unis la coalition en afghanistan
donc la russie avait donné certaines
facilités de transfert de transport aux
troupes qui se rendaient en afghanistan
sont naturellement envisager la moindre
intervention elle même aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être l'organisation de coopération
de shanghai dans laquelle se retrouvent
une partie des pays que j'ai cité
notamment la chine et la russie mais
aussi l'inde et le pakistan mais aussi
comme observateurs
l'iran et l'afghanistan qui pourrait
être appelé à jouer un rôle un rôle
modérateur
alors lé pakistan font les talibans
pardon font la tournée des capitales
pour essayer de rassurer en disant mais
nous n'avons aucune vision d'extension
d'intervention extérieure simplement ne
voulons plus d'étrangers qui
interviennent dans les affaires dans les
affaires intérieures de l'afghanistan au
pardon que peut-on espérer justement que
l'eau des négociations en cours avec les
talibans parlons alors que je veux dire
il est négocié et le montre il se montre
sous un jour favorable en essayant de
rassurer les uns et les autres avec un
niveau de crédibilité à ces faibles
parce que historiquement ils ont abrité
des terroristes qui les talibans
eux-mêmes n'intervenez pas à l'étranger
mais les terroristes qu'ils abritaient
intervenait à l'étranger et on sait
aujourd'hui qu'un certain nombre de
groupes terroristes ne sont conseillés
des talibans et qu'ils n'ont pas que
talibans n'ont pas rompu contrairement à
ce qu'ils disent tout lien avec al qaïda
ou avec un certain nombre d'autres
groupes terroristes
donc la négociation en cours
probablement retardera les défiances
mais n'empêchera probablement pas les
talibans de parvenir au pouvoir sur la
plus grande partie du territoire afghan
et finalement la grande question ce sera
d'ici peut-être quelques mois ou une
année le sort de kaboul de la capitale
effectivement les pays voisins ont
cherché à établir un mode easy vingt dix
sans doute avec les packs qui avec les
talibans il est possible qu'ils arrivent
il est possible que les chances soient
retardés mais pour cela les talibans
devant
dégage et ne sont pas prêts les beaucoup
de gages sauf encore une fois à
s'engager à ne pas encourager
d'intervention à l'extérieur et à rompre
leurs relations avec les groupes
terroristes
ils ont d'ailleurs laissé partir les
troupes américaines conformément à leurs
engagements vis-à-vis des américains
sans les attaquer donc il est possible
sans doute de conclure des accords très
limitée avec les talibans mais des
accords sans grande sans grandes
illusions et les victimes de cette
situation
ce seront ce sera la population afghane
une fois de plus beaucoup d'afghans ont
partir ça va faire une source de
migrations considérable vers l'europe
qu'il faudra traiter d'ailleurs d'ores
et déjà les pays qui ont combattu en
afghanistan
accueil où se prépare à accueillir tout
ou partie des afghans qui ont travaillé
avec eux merci beaucoup claude pour
toutes ces précisions sur le dossier
afghan claude blanchou maison c'était
elle est dite et diplo de la matinale
merci